[Music]
this week we have again compiled lots of
exciting news for you among other topics
we talk about Henry cavill's official
statement on his role as Superman a
first image from the Joker sequel the
late continuation of a film series with
Jackie Chan and exciting news from
Christopher Nolan's latest film
Oppenheimer furthermore Timothy chalamet
recently announced important progress on
the production of Dune part 2 and Amazon
revealed how the planned God of War
series will proceed if that has caught
your attention then keep on watching
Amazon managed to acquire a number of
video game adaptations lately in
addition to life is strange Fallout Mass
Effect Gears of War and disco Elysium
the popular God of War franchise will
also get a series production on the
series has been underway since March and
has now been given the go-ahead by the
responsible parties the series will not
be based on the old games but on the two
latest PlayStation hits the plot of the
new games from developer Santa Monica
Studios is set in the Norse mythological
world the story is about the God of War
Kratos who after the death of his wife
sets out with the son atreus to cope
with the loss and spread her ashes as
requested on their Adventure the two
first emotionally distinct characters
have to face many friends and enemies
which they meet on their long way
through several Nordic worlds showrunner
of the God of War series will be Rafe
Judkins who was already responsible for
The Wheel of Time in the same position
there is still no reliable information
about the cast but many would like to
see Christopher Judge on the role since
he already dubbed the character in the
last two parts in theory however there
is a whole range of candidates for the
heavily muscled character with Gabe
Batista for example frequently being
mentioned as a fan favorite sadly there
is also no information on a detailed
plot or release date yet but now that
the series has officially been given the
green light there ought to be new
details soon
it's not getting any quieter at DC these
days only last week reports about the
plant restructuring of the dceu caused
quite a stir in Hollywood the list of
affected projects is long for instance
Wonder Woman 3 Black Adam 2 and Aquaman
3 will be canceled the idea is to create
a completely new universe that is no
longer connected to the so-called
snyderverse equally affected was Man of
Steel 2 which ironically was even teased
at the end of Black Adam this will have
been the last appearance of Henry Cavill
in his popular role as he now confirmed
in an official statement thus Peter
Safran and James Gunn the two heads of
DC Studios have met him and presented
him their plans he himself respects the
decision of the two after all they must
also create a completely new universe
but still it is not easy for him on the
other hand it has to be pointed out that
gun and saffron only recently took over
their positions as creative directors of
DC which is why they are only partly to
blame for the chaotic back and forth
nevertheless one thing is certain there
are plans for Superman in the upcoming
dceu as gun announced almost
simultaneously with cattle statement in
contrast to a Man of Steel 2 there will
be a kind of prequel that shows the
superhero in his younger years Gunn
himself will write the corresponding
script and possibly also take over the
directing despite the disappointment
that many fans of Henry Cavill surely
feel the new project does at least raise
some curiosity whatever the outcome we
will keep you up to date on further news
last year Dennis Villa nueva's Dune won
six Academy Awards out of 10 nominations
outshining all of its competitors the
Epic film is based on the 1965 book by
Frank Herbert and revolves around young
Paul Atreides who finds himself in a
confusing situation that not only takes
his father's life but also forces the
ruling a triades family underground a
second part was announced promptly after
the success of the first part and will
most likely be a bit more extensive on
Instagram Timothy chalamet personally
confirmed that filming which began this
summer is now completed Hungary Italy
and Abu Dhabi among others were used as
filming locations especially the latter
seems to be the ideal place for the
desert scenery where part 1 was also
shot for the most part in addition to
the familiar Stars around Timothy
chalamet Zendaya Rebecca Ferguson
Stellan Skarsgard and Josh Brolin some
new faces also join the cast these are
not strangers to Hollywood either with
the likes of Florence Pugh as Princess
erulin and and Christopher Walken as her
father Emperor shaddam IV Dennis Villa
Nueve is once again the director in
addition to him John Spates and Eric
Roth have also contributed to the script
which is exactly the same constellation
as in the predecessor we are looking
forward to further news and of course to
a first trailer with which those
responsible will probably take some more
time the theatrical release is not until
November 3rd 2023 in a little less than
a year
with Joker from 2019 director Todd
Phillips succeeded in making the most
successful R-rated film of all time up
to now in total the completely
Standalone film which has no connection
to the dceu or the Batman grossed over 1
billion dollars at the box office almost
250 million dollars more than the second
place to film Deadpool 2. so it's not
surprising that all eyes are on the long
confirmed sequel titled Joker Foley
adieu with expectations being
correspondingly high a few days ago
there were two main reasons for fans to
look forward to the sequel first
shooting has officially started as
director Todd Phillips announced on
social media second there is a first
image of the film it shows topless
leading man Joaquin Phoenix being shaped
by an unknown person based on the white
coat of the person on the left we can
assume that this scene takes place in
the infamous Arkham Asylum as of yet
there is not much information regarding
the plot but we already know that the
movie will be told in a musical style
and it is also certain that Harley Quinn
will take on a major role in the sequel
this also fits the title Folia Dew which
is named after a psychotic disorder in
which delusions are transferred from one
sick individual to an initially healthy
person literally translated fully adieu
thus means Madness shared by two since
Harley Quinn who will be played by Lady
Gaga was one of the psychiatrists in
Arkham Asylum according to the comics it
seems reasonable to assume that she is
the one who gets affected by the Joker's
mental illness in addition to Joaquin
Phoenix and Lady Gaga zazi beats returns
with Harry Potter actor Brendan Gleason
and Being John Malkovich actress
Catherine Keener also making their
debuts the theatrical release of Joker
Foley adieu has so far been scheduled
for October 4th 2024.
it's a well-known fact that director
Christopher Nolan is a gifted filmmaker
who doesn't shy away from any challenge
in his new film Oppenheimer which
revolves around the invention of the
atomic bomb in the course of the second
world war a massive nuclear explosion
cannot be missing it would probably have
been easiest to recreate the detonation
via CGI but Nolan resorted to Mechanical
means instead needless to say a real
atomic bomb was not detonated but the
so-called Trinity nuclear explosion
which was the first atomic bomb
detonation ever is said to have been
recreated in a deceptively realistic way
the outcome is of course unknown but it
is likely to increase anticipation for
the film even more additionally there
are a number of images released
exclusively by total film the images
feature Robert Downey Jr as Louis
Strauss who is barely recognizable in
appearance Killian Murphy as nuclear
bomb inventor Robert J Oppenheimer along
with behind the scenes shots of Nolan as
well as two covers the movie is also
said to be the very first to be shot in
entirely in IMAX black and white which
is certainly consistent with the wartime
and post-war atmosphere the cast is also
very impressive with Downey Jr and
Murphy being joined by Florence Pugh
Gary Oldman and Ramy Malek in various
roles we are looking forward to the
Nolan biopic about the father of the
atomic bomb which is scheduled for
release on July 21st 2023.
actor Jackie Chan took to the stage at
the Red Sea film festival few expected
him to announce a sequel to an iconic
movie series completely unexpectedly
chance spoke of an upcoming Rush Hour 4
that was now officially in the works
that same evening he said he had
arranged a meeting with the director to
reveal his plans red Ratner has directed
all three Rush Hour movies to date the
last installment came out 15 years ago
and ratner's last time directing was in
2014 for Hercules in 2017 when the
director was also confronted with
accusations of sexual harassment Warner
Brothers ended all contracts with the 53
year old and his company Rat Pack thus
the announcement of a sequel came as a
great surprise and an actual engagement
of Ratner as a director is considered
very unlikely in terms of plot the
popular comedy movie series revolves
around inspector Lee who was tasked by
the Chinese Consul to conduct
investigations in Los Angeles under the
supervision of local police officer
James Carter later the two become
friends and saw various cases together
due to its funny and distinctive style
the movie series is still very famous
today which is mainly due to the
chemistry of the two main actors Jackie
Chan and Chris Tucker a planned release
date is not known yet which is not
really strange considering the very
early stage of production stay tuned for
further news
alright that's it for this week we
suggest you check out the latest
Spider-Man across the spider-verse
trailer on our channel in addition we
also got a new original episode on
Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3 in which
you can learn everything you need to
know about the final Guardians movie
thanks for watching and see you next
week
laughs
[Music]